Це символ Франції - Версаль.
А отже - потенційна ціль терористів.
Поліцейський Максім Реньов  знає, що туристи
передусім тут, у черзі до проходження контролю безпеки,
особливо вразливі.
Тому він та його колеги постійно насторожі.
Перед минулими атаками терористи ретельно вивчали об'єкт
перед тим, як учинити теракт.
- Ми стежимо за людьми, які дивно поводяться
і можуть становити небезпеку. Наприклад, люди,
які просто сидять і роблять нотатки чи фото.
Або люди, які фотографують з автомобіля та їдуть далі.
Їх ми одразу контролюємо.
Французькі поліцейські перебувають у постійній готовності відтоді,
як країною прокотилася серія жорстоких терористичних атак.
Понад 240 загиблих за менш як чотири роки.
Поліцейські повинні цьому запобігти
в будь-який момент і в будь-якому місці.
Минулого року французькі поліцейські
загалом перепрацювали 22 мільйони годин.
Це в сумі понад 900 тисяч днів.
- Ми на передовій, щоб захистити символи Франції.
Проживати це щодня доволі важко.
Якщо справді станеться терористичний акт,
ми не повинні думати про своє життя.
Ми повинні потурбуватися про безпеку інших.
У випадку атаки Максім та його колеги
більше не повинні чекати на елітні загони.
У минулому вони часто приїздили надто пізно.
Максім повинен сам втрутитися, щоб зупинити ймовірного терориста.
Поліцейських готують до цього на навчаннях,
забезпечують куленепробивними жилетами та кращою зброєю.
Утім, для багатьох це занадто. Їм страшно,
адже останніми роками самі поліцейські дедалі частіше ставали ціллю терористів.
13 липня 2016 року ісламіст убив
у передмісті Парижа подружню пару поліцейських
на очах у їхнього трирічного сина.
Це був шок для всіх французів.
- Я не хочу сказати, що має місце психоз серед поліцейських,
адже вони залишаються на службі.
Але ми, поліцейські, знаємо, що є люди, які готові
переслідувати нас та наші родини.
Брак відпочинку, ворожі напади, страх тероризму.
Багато хто не витримує навантаження.
Минулого року понад 60 французьких поліцейських
вчинили самогубство. Часто це ставалося у комісаріатах.
Сенатор з Лотарингії вивчив ці випадки та б'є на сполох.
- Ми повинні повністю оновити безпековий апарат.
Треба покращити менеджмент і більше інвестувати в безпеку.
Поліцейські пости треба оновити, службовцям потрібні кращі автомобілі.
Ідеться врешті-решт про нашу безпеку.
Будь-яка інша служба теж цього вимагала б.
Поліцейськіий Реньов не вважає, що
цього достатньо для вирішення проблеми.
Загроза залишається. Непомітна, але вона є.
До 2019 року з в'язниці повинні вийти понад 40 небезпечних джихадистів,
строки ув'язнення яких спливають.
Боротьба проти тероризму стала тепер частиною життя Максіма.
- Людина стає поліцейським, бо колись хотіла
хапати грабіжників, гралася в жандарма і любить екшн.
Але нині я часто йду додому з думкою, що щасливий, бо нічого не трапилося.
Утім, навіть якщо його професія набула геть іншого виміру,
Реньов не хоче здаватися і залишати свою роботу.